Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Pritlav und ich begrüße alle zur UKW Nummer 109 vom 23. Februar 2023.
Also heute nehmen wir auf, mal gucken ob ich veröffentlich kriege das heute eh nicht mehr.
Aber dann sind wir dann sozusagen pünktlich mit allen anderen am Start,
um ein Jahr nach dem Krieg der Ukraine, Also nachdem dieser Krieg begonnen hat,
auch nochmal unseren Senf zur aktuellen Lage zu geben.
Und das mache ich natürlich mit Pawel. Hallo Pawel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, jetzt haben wir schon wieder so wie bei Corona, diesen Moment,
wo wir feststellen so, ein Jahr schon, wie lange wird es wohl noch gehen?
Oder? Hier grüßt echt das Murmeltier.
Und die Frage ist genauso deprimierend in gewisser Hinsicht,
wie sie das bei Corona auch schon war.
Wobei bei Corona fast noch eher irgendwie in Sicht war, dass sich da was tut und verändert.
Da war halt warten auf die Impfstoffe und dann die Mutationen und so.
Es war schon doch eine ganze Menge Ungewissheit drin.
Ich meine, wer dann sozusagen von Optimismus geprägt war und wer nicht,
das ist nochmal eine andere Frage.
Ich hatte meinen Optimismus eigentlich immer in der Tasche, nur haben sich die
Ereignisse nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig immer so ergeben.
Und das ist auch jetzt hier so.
Na ja, wir wollen jetzt mal die Gelegenheit nutzen und zwar mehr,
weil wir seit einem schon nichts mehr dazu gesagt haben, als statt jetzt hier
wirklich eine Jahreszusammenfassung zu machen, einfach noch mal auf diesen Konflikt
zu blicken, beziehungsweise auf verschiedene Aspekte.
Heute vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Meta als konkrete Berichterstattung.
Aber ein bisschen Konkretes haben wir auch.
Ja, ein bisschen Konkretes haben wir natürlich auch und ich würde auch sagen,
damit sollten wir dann auch einfach mal beginnen. Also wir hatten letzten Monat,
die letzte Sendung war am 22.
Januar, wenn ich mich jetzt nähe, Entschuldigung, am 27. Januar kam die raus.
Und da war so die Situation, dass sich eigentlich der ganze Konflikt militärisch
ziemlich festgefressen hatte.
Also es gab verhältnismäßig wenig Bewegungen, es gab Stellen,
wo die Russen mehr Alarm gemacht haben, es gab Stellen, wo die Ukrainer mehr Alarm gemacht haben.
Und das große Fragezeichen war immer die ganze Zeit, welchen Einfluss wird vor
allem das Wetter haben? Und wem wird welches Wetter mehr in die Karten spielen?
Es gab so ein bisschen die optimistische Erwartung, dass ein harter,
kalter Winter vor allem die Russen mehr treffen wird, schlechtere Ausrüstung etc.
Ja, und den Ukrainern gegebenenfalls eine Gelegenheit für eine Gegeneffensive gibt.
Aber nun macht es eher so den Eindruck, als ob eher die Russen die Situation
für sich haben nutzen können,
allerdings unter einem Auffang, wo man auch irgendwie nur noch die Augen verschließen möchte.
Was passiert ist, ist, dass sie eigentlich an verschiedenen Fronten und insbesondere
rund um diese Stadt Bachmuth,
die wir hier auch schon erwähnt haben, das ist so keine Schlüsselstadt im eigentlichen Sinne,
aber die Stadt, an der die Russen am nächsten dran sind im Donbass,
wo sie seit Monaten versuchen in irgendeiner Form den Widerstand der Ukrainer
zu brechen und bis vor einem Monat da auch nicht wirklich weiter gekommen sind.
Und das hat sich dann doch ein bisschen geändert. Und der Grund dafür ist.
Immer ein bisschen schwierig zu beschreiben, aber es hat weniger mit Taktik zu tun,
als damit, dass die Russen ein bisschen weggekommen sind von ihren bisherigen Angriffsmethoden,
die auf großem Atelierieinsatz und dann eben mechanisierten Einsatz,
also sprich dann mit Fahrzeugen hinterherzukommen.
Das ist so diese klassische Methode gewesen, mit der die Russen ganze Zeit schon
versucht haben, Erfolge zu erzielen.
Also wir haben halt viel Artillerie, dann wird den ganzen Tag alles zugehagelt
an der Front mit Artillerie und wenn in irgendeiner Form ersichtlich ist,
dass der Widerstand des Gegners dort gebrochen wurde dadurch,
dann versucht man eben massiv mit Geräten da rein zu ziehen und das zu überrollen.
Das ist so immer mit dem Kopf durch die Wand, das ist so ein bisschen die Methode
des russischen Militärs,
die nicht überall, die ja ganz am Anfang, den allerersten Tagen ein bisschen Erfolg hatte im Süden,
aber danach eigentlich nie so richtig funktioniert hat und immer wieder vom
ukrainischen Militär ausgetrickst wurde oder mit entsprechendem Widerstand begegnet wurde.
Jetzt sind sie auf eine andere Methode umgestiegen und setzen vor allem auf
Infanterie und setzen halt einfach Unmengen an Personen,
die sie eben jetzt durch die Mobilisierung in den letzten Monaten gewonnen haben,
ein und schicken die einfach in Wellen an die Front, egal wie groß die Verluste sind.
Und die Verluste sind groß. Nach ukrainischen Schätzungen gehen da also pro
Tag 600 bis 1000 Menschen bei drauf, bei den Russen. Die Verluste bei Ukraine
ist sicherlich jetzt auch nicht gering, aber die kennen wir so nicht.
Ja und mit diesem, es ist halt so ein bisschen was von Zombie-Angriff,
also die Leute werden da einfach ohne viel Gerät an die Front geworfen und überrennen
einfach diese Positionen und da ist es dann halt den Russen gelungen im Norden
der Stadt Bachmuth eine relativ wichtige Stadt einzunehmen,
Söderda, die auch lange, lange lange Zeit schon gekämpft wurde,
so dass im Norden wie auch im Süden der Stadt auf diese Art und Weise mittlerweile
die ukrainische Front doch enorm zurückgedrängt wurde und es jetzt so ein bisschen aussieht,
als könnte in den nächsten Wochen Bachmuth dann tatsächlich auch an die Russen
fallen, auch wenn die Einschätzungen da noch unterschiedlich sind.
Kann sich auch noch ein bisschen hinziehen, aber ganz ausschließen lässt es
sich derzeit einfach nicht.
Also, mein Bachmut befindet sich ja jetzt schon seit Wochen oder Monaten so.
Ist es jetzt bedroht, ist auch jetzt, ich sag mal so halb eingekesselt,
kann man sagen, also im Norden und im Süden.
Wobei es wohl dann auch gelungen ist, den Vormarsch im Norden und im Süden dann
jeweils auch zum Halten zu bringen oder zurückzuschlagen.
Und mein Eindruck ist auch.
Dass so zwischendurch, als sie da General Armageddon als Oberbefehlshaber hatten,
der dann auch den Rückzug aus Teilen von von Kasson organisiert hat und dann
ja, angefangen hat, ein bisschen erst mal vorsichtiger zu operieren.
Der ist ja jetzt wieder von Gerasimov abgesetzt worden und ausgetauscht worden.
Seitdem scheint ja dann wieder diese erwartete russische Offensive möglicherweise
angefangen zu haben. Das ist ja auch das Verrückte.
Alle haben auf die russische Offensive gewartet und dann war aber jetzt unklar,
ist das, was wir in den letzten zwei Wochen oder so beobachtet haben,
war das jetzt schon die Offensive und kommt die jetzt nicht so richtig aus den
Pötten oder halten die Russen sich jetzt zurück und,
Und die große Offensive jetzt noch, das geht jetzt schon seit Wochen so,
dass man auf die russische Offensive wartet und irgendwas Offensivartiges wohl stattfindet.
Aber eben, ja, es unklar ist. Sind die Russen jetzt einfach erschöpft,
sodass die Offensive noch nicht mal als Offensive zu erkennen sind oder kommt
da noch was? Was denkst du?
Also ich denke, es ist schon der Versuch war, eine Offensive zu starten,
weil derzeit ist das Zeitfenster wettertechnisch noch ganz gut.
Also in zwei Wochen soll es dann wieder tauen.
Dann geht quasi die nächste Matsch-Saison los. Und das haben wir ja schon zu
Beginn des Krieges gesehen, wie gut das für die Russen funktioniert hat.
Also das ist natürlich auch eine Einschränkung für die Ukraine in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also das erlaubt genauso wenig jetzt einen Vorstoß, einen unmittelbaren.
Aber für die Ukraine könnte jetzt dieser Wetterumschwung genau zum richtigen
Zeitpunkt kommen, um einfach die Fortschritte der Russen, die sie jetzt gemacht
haben, da an der Stelle auch einzufrieren, aufzutauen.
Es gab ja ähnliche Angriffe, nicht nur um Bachmuth, sondern es gab das Ganze
auch im Norden von Luhansk, wo sie versucht haben, Boden wieder gut zu machen
und das teilweise hier und da auch getan haben.
Da reden wir dann halt immer von Kilometer oder sowas, wo vorgestoßen wurde,
wo es auch so richtig desaströs gelaufen ist, wo die Russen ja auch ziemlich
panisch versuchen, Land zu gewinnen, ist um den Ort Wuledar herum.
Riesige Verluste, auch materielle Verluste, nicht nur Personal, sondern auch was,
was ich an einem Tag habe, also ich habe versucht da mit irgendwie 30 Fahrzeugen,
davon die Hälfte glaube ich Panzer, irgendwie die ukrainischen Stellungen zu
umfahren, das ist komplett in die Hose gegangen.
Da haben sie also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob die alle zerstört wurden
oder teilweise sogar auch noch gecaptured wurden von der Ukraine.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie die nicht wieder mit zurückgenommen.
Die Verluste sind da extrem und die Fortschritte sind also quasi gleich null.
Also im Großen und Ganzen kann man sagen, es geht zwar derzeit für die Ukraine nirgendswo voran,
aber die Verluste jetzt in territorialen Einheiten gemessen halten sich in Grenzen.
Ob sich die Verluste in Form von Menschenleben in irgendeiner Form in Grenzen halten,
da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, das dürfte derzeit einfach ein extrem
blutiger Kampf sein und wenn man sich so verschiedene Videos anschaut,
dann hat das alles so diesen totalen World War One Vibe.
Also Kampf wirklich in den Gräben, Mann gegen Mann, Überfälle mit leichten Schusswaffen
und alles super böse und blutig und einfach überhaupt keine Freude sich das anzuschauen.
Aber Aber das ist halt einfach jetzt mal die Realität on the ground.
Und ich denke, dass die Ukraine derzeit in so einem ähnlichen Modus ist wie von einem halben Jahr,
als die Russen im Donbass so stark gedrückt haben,
wo es um Lissichansk und Svevjero-Donec ging, um diese Städte,
die sie dann letztlich auch verloren haben, aber die eben für die Russen auch
so kostlich waren, dass sie ja dann eben auf diese neue Mobilisierung umschalten mussten.
Und es eben für die Ukrainer vor allem ein Zeitgewinn war.
Und diese These des Zeitgewinnens, die erscheint recht plausibel.
Wenn wir jetzt mal auf die militärische Situation in Bezug auf Ausrüstung schauen,
haben wir ja in den letzten Wochen und Monaten diese ganze Debatte um Panzerlieferungen miterlebt,
die von Ukraine quasi von Tag eins an gefordert wurden,
aber wo halt der Westen sich sehr zurückhaltend geäußert hat,
aber wenn wir jetzt mal schauen, wo wir jetzt in einem Jahr hingekommen sind,
von Deutschland spendet 5000 Helme zu einer jetzt von der deutschen Regierung
zugesagten Lieferung von relativ modernen Leopard 2 Panzern,
also diese A6-Modelle, die im Prinzip zugesagt wurden,
sind jetzt kein altes Zeug,
sondern das ist schon nicht das aller aller neuste aber
das ist sagen wir mal im vergleich zu dem was die ukraine derzeit hat schon
wirklich ein riesen sprung nach vorne technisch aber damit ist ja auch verbunden
dass sie eben allen anderen ländern auch erlauben leopard panzer zu liefern Ja,
also zu den Panzern kommen wir ja gleich noch ein bisschen im Detail,
aber mein Eindruck von der Gesamtsituation ist,
dass die für eine Offensivübermacht.
Also um erfolgreiche Offensiven zu führen, braucht man halt kräftemäßig eine
Überlegenheit von drei zu eins, idealerweise eigentlich eher 10 zu 1,
die man irgendwo konzentriert.
Also es muss jetzt nicht über die gesamte Front 10 zu 1 sein,
aber da wo man durchbrechen will mit 10 zu 1 über Macht, hält man die eigenen
Verluste in Grenzen und hat eine sehr hohe Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit.
Und wenn das jetzt nicht gelingt und so sieht es aus,
dass jetzt im Moment es keiner Seite gelingt,
irgendwie so eine ausreichende Offensivübermacht aufzubauen und weshalb die
Ukraine sich dann eher entschieden hat,
eher defensiv im Moment zu agieren, weil sie eben nicht das Gefühl haben,
genug übermacht zu haben, während die Russen eher der Meinung sind, na ja...
Wir müssen es halt irgendwie probieren oder probieren es halt,
ohne ausreichende Offensivmacht zu haben und dementsprechend kleinfallen halt
die Fortschritte und entsprechend groß die Verluste aus.
Und auf der anderen Seite hat aber im Gegensatz zum Sommer,
jetzt habe ich die Ukraine sich entschieden, beispielsweise
auch in in bachmut mehr zu investieren
als es jetzt aus strategischer sicht
sinnvoll oder aus
taktischer sicht sinnvoll wäre sondern aus strategischen überlegungen nämlich
unterstützung durch den westen und symbolische bedeutung jetzt auch mehr in
den kampf um bachmut investieren als es eigentlich wert ist Und ja,
das ist jetzt die Situation.
Die Frage ist halt, wann gelingt es einer Seite, die entsprechende Übermacht aufzubauen.
Und das kann entweder gelingen, indem man einfach Reserven zurückhält und aufbaut
und aufbaut und aufbaut und dann eben konzentriert.
So eine entsprechende Übermacht. Also mit 10 zu 1 ist jetzt nicht gemeint zehnmal
so viele Truppen, sondern Truppen in einer Quantität und einer Qualität,
dass sie die zehnfache Kampfkraft haben.
Das kann jetzt doppelt so viel, also was weiß ich, vierfache Qualität und zweifache
numerische Überlegenheit oder so. Kann das sein.
Und diese Übermacht kann natürlich auch entstehen, wenn die verteidigende Seite,
wenn der entweder die Munition oder der Sprit oder die Manpower ausgeht.
So eins davon kann dann eben auch dafür sorgen,
dass selbst wenn die andere Seite nicht stärker wird, sondern nur seine Kraft
hält, dass quasi die verteidigende Seite nur noch ein Zehntel so stark ist wie
am Anfang, dann hat es so auch die Übermachtssituation.
Das heißt, eines dieser Szenarien wäre aber nötig, damit die Front wieder in Bewegung kommt.
Das ist natürlich der Wunschstraum der Ukraine, das zu erzielen und die Forderungen dazu sind ja lang.
Also neben der Panzerfrage gibt es auch den langgehegten Wunsch nach Long Range
Missiles, wo jetzt wieder sehr viel Bewegung reingekommen ist.
Die Amerikaner haben jetzt verschiedene Systeme zugesagt und es gibt auch schon
die ersten Gerüchte aus der letzten Woche,
dass bestimmte Angriffe, die von der Ukraine durchgeführt wurden,
die waren so an so Stellen, die...
Mariupol.
In Mariupol zum Beispiel, genau so ein bisschen im Hinterland von Indonezk etc.
Also jenseits dieser 70 Kilometer Marke, wo man derzeit so mit High-Mars-Raketen
sehr präzise hat zuschlagen können, geschehen auf einmal auch sehr genaue Angriffe.
Und das ist noch so ein bisschen unklar, was es damit auf sich hat,
aber es macht so ganz den Eindruck, als ob die schon vor einiger Zeit zu gesagten GLSDB-Systeme,
das sind so im Prinzip so Upgrades für dumme Munition,
die dann halt so eine Gleitoption noch mit dazu bekommt mit so ausklappbaren
Flügeln und mit GPS- Steuerung, die dann halt sehr viel weiter fliegen können
und dann trotzdem sehr genau ins Ziel gebracht werden können.
Das kann also sein, dass es noch so ein bisschen unkonfirmed,
dass dieser Punkt schon erreicht hat. Und das ist natürlich,
Das klingt so wie so eine Kleinigkeit.
Aber tatsächlich, so wie diese Heimas-Raketen ja einen riesen Unterschied gemacht
haben vor einem halben Jahr,
weil auf einmal die Russen ihre komplette Zulieferlogistik umbauen mussten,
alle großen Lager sehr viel mehr ins Hinterland verlegen mussten und dann sich
entsprechend die Zulieferwege zur Front verkompliziert haben.
Genauso könnte jetzt eine noch höhere Reichweite von extrem präziser Munition
diesen Prozess noch ein weiteres Mal treiben und hätte dann die interessante Auswirkungen,
dass es zwar im Donbass sozusagen bedeutet, dass noch mal so 20,
30, 50 Kilometer weiter man nach hinten treten muss.
Das ist dann vielleicht nicht einfach, aber in gewisser Hinsicht noch machbar.
Aber in diesem dünnen Streifen zwischen der Frontlinie und dem Asowschen Meer,
Also von Mariopol auf der einen Seite bis zum Übergang zur Krim auf der anderen
Seite, da gibt es da nicht mehr so viel Rückraum.
Da müssten sie sozusagen ihre Lager ins Wasser verlegen, das ist natürlich keine Option.
Wenn also die Ukraine über Waffen verfügt, die an der Stelle wirklich extrem
präzise zuschlagen können und alle Truppen- und Munitionskonzentrationen dann
eben vernichtet, bevor sie überhaupt zum Einsatz kommen, dann haben die Russen
auf jeden Fall wieder ein großes Problem.
Also wie du sagst, die GLSDB soll angeblich noch nicht in der Ukraine sein,
laut amerikanischen Angaben.
Die sollen erst im Laufe des Jahres geliefert werden. Das ist meine letzte Information,
aber das ist jetzt nicht ausgeschlossen. Das ist schon mal ein kleineres Kontingent.
Ja, es ist halt so, man kann sich eben bestimmte Angriffe gerade nicht so richtig erklären.
Mit welcher Munition die so durchgeführt worden sind. Eine andere Möglichkeit
sind die türkischen Waffentieferungen, die es ja auch gab.
Ja, und die Engländer haben auch von nicht näher spezifizierten Langstreckenwaffen
gesprochen, die sie der Ukraine zur Verfügung stellen wollten,
wo sie sich aber bedeckt gehalten haben.
Darüber könnte es sich auch um diese Waffen handeln. oder es könnte auch irgendwas
sein, was die Ukraine selbst produziert.
In der Lage, so ein bisschen eigene Langstreckenwaffen zu produzieren.
Ja, und gut, in dem Zusammenhang auch noch aktuell wurde auch noch angekündigt,
dass die USA JDAM-ER-Kits liefert.
JDAMs sind im Prinzip dumme Bomben. Bomben, das ist eine Joint Direct Attack
Munition und ER steht dann für Extended Range,
das heißt, das sind so Prinzip-Kits, die man auf dumme Bomben schraubt,
die dann Flügel ausklappen können und dann per GPS ins Ziel geleitet werden
unter Umständen auch mit Waypoints,
also fliegen das nicht direkt an und die können dann halt bis 70 Kilometer dann
noch im Gleitflug zurücklegen,
aber müssen meines Wissens aus von Flugzeugen natürlich abgeworfen werden.
Vorteil von denen dann wiederum gegenüber Jetzt GLSDB ist, dass diese JDAMs
in 230 bis 910 Kilogramm Sprengkraft kommen.
Das heißt, das sind halt richtig dicke Bomben, die vor allen Dingen dann auch
gegen Brücken oder andere harte Ziele einsetzbar sind.
Das scheint aber alles im Wesentlichen noch zu kommen und noch nicht aktuell verfügbar zu sein.
Aber es macht auf jeden Fall gerade diese Kaskade von Zusagen von den USA.
Macht zunehmend so diesen Eindruck, als ob es schon einen sehr langfristigen
Plan gibt, wann man was wie macht und das hängt natürlich nicht unbedingt nur
von der politischen Bereitschaft ab. Die ist in gewisser Hinsicht ja da.
Klar, Finanzierbarkeit etc. Aber so dieses, wir liefern euch nicht,
weil das könnte jetzt irgendwie Russland aufregen.
Ich glaube, dieses Thema ist irgendwie langsam durch. Also in den USA zumindest.
Naja, es kommt ja wirklich Schritt für Schritt. Es kommt ja wirklich jetzt so,
alle paar Wochen wird das nächste Waffenpaket angekündigt und mittlerweile gibt
es ja so recht keinen Halten mehr, was so die Technologie betrifft.
Zum Panzern kommen wir gleich nochmal im Detail. Die einzige Steigerung,
die jetzt noch aussteht, also von Waffengattungen sozusagen,
die bisher noch überhaupt nicht zugesagt wurden und die von der Ukraine aber
gewollt werden, Flugzeuge.
Wobei es halt so aus Großbritannien schon so die ersten Bereitschaftssignale
gibt, zu sagen so ja, ja, kommt doch, schickt doch schon mal eure Piloten,
wir bilden die schon mal aus.
Naja, die UK hat wohl Eurofighter zugesagt, so wie es aussieht.
Ja, und die Amerikaner bilden halt auf, glaube ich, auf F-16 schon aus.
So, das ist da, glaube ich, der Stand.
Genau, also ich rechne schon damit, dass wir im Laufe des Krieges das dann auch
noch sehen werden als weitere Eskalationsstufe.
Nur, ist ja nicht so, du holst sie ja nicht aus dem Hangar und dann setzt sie
aufs Schiff und dann fährst du sie dahin und wenn die damit nutzt,
dann erfordert ja eben erstmal ausgebildetes Personal, aber das bedeutet ja
auch, du brauchst eine Infrastruktur, du brauchst einen Standort,
brauchst Wartungsteams etc.
Die ganze Versorgung, also da hängt eine riesige Logistik dran,
insbesondere Kampfflugzeuge, die müssen für jede Stunde, die die fliegen,
müssen einfach mehrere Stunden gewartet werden, sonst sind die halt in 0,X im
Eimer und das ist als alles etwas, das muss erst mal aufgebaut werden.
Aber gerade bei diesen JDAM-ER habe ich mich halt gefragt, so ok,
können die dann eben auch für die Flugzeuge, mit denen die Ukraine derzeit fliegt,
überhaupt angepasst werden?
Also können die da überhaupt drauf verwendet werden? Ich bin mir da gerade nicht ganz so sicher.
Aber eher eine lange Liste von westlichen Flugzeugen gesehen,
für die die gemacht sind.
Ja, unklar.
Aber ich würde sagen, möglich ist es schon.
Ja, die bauen dann irgendwelche Adapter noch dazu. Das gab es ja jetzt auch schon mehrere Male.
Weil an sich sind es halt dumme Bomben.
So, also und entweder man kann ja auch vorher am Boden programmieren auf das
Ziel und dann erreicht im einfachsten Fall einen Knopf, um die Dinger abzuwerfen.
Und ja, also ganz, ganz so schwierig kann das nicht sein, aber wir werden sehen, wie die das machen.
Kommen wir noch mal vielleicht zu dieser Hauptgeschichte der letzten Wochen,
nämlich die Lieferung der Leopardpanzer.
Also wie schon angedeutet, das war ja politisch eine echt heiße Kartoffel und ehrlich gesagt,
ich hatte so den Eindruck, Deutschland macht sich komplett zum Horst,
aber dann gab es dann schon irgendwann so diesen Punkt,
wobei man merkte, okay, alles klar, die Front weicht langsam auf und dann wie
schon so ein paar Mal war das eben so, wenn dann die Entscheidung kommt,
dann fällt sie dann auf einmal doch profunder aus, als man das gedacht hatte.
Also nicht nur, dass die Deutschen jetzt Leopaten liefern,
sie liefern halt moderne Leopaten, sie liefern auch eine signifikante Zahl oder
zumindest haben sie eine signifikante
Zahl in Aussicht gestellt und bilden natürlich jetzt auch schon aus.
Da hat das sicherlich auch ein bisschen geholfen, dass das Verteidigungsministerium
einen Wechsel gab, auch wenn es natürlich am Ende eine Kanzlerentscheidung ist, ganz klar.
Aber dieser Boris Pistorius macht ja wirklich einen komplett anderen Eindruck als seine Vorgängerin.
Ja und dann war halt die Ansage auch an den Rest von Europa ja okay dann schickt
doch mal eure Leoparden.
Und da war dann eben große Zurückhaltung zu spüren. Auf einmal wollte dann keiner
mehr so richtig, ich glaube so richtig zugesagt hat derzeit nur Portugal und
die anderen halten sich noch alle ein bisschen bedeckt. Da wird also noch gerungen.
War ganz interessant, wie sie alle auf Deutschland gezeigt haben,
aber Hauptnass Deutschland gesagt hat, ja okay, gut, dann meint wegen und dann
ihr zeigt mal euer Blatt und dann waren sie halt selber alle ein bisschen zurückhaltender
in diesem ganzen Gepokere um Unterstützung.
Womit ich jetzt nicht sagen will, dass sie anderen Länder keine Unterstützung
liefern, aber gerade diese Panzerfrage scheint irgendwie extrem sensitiv zu sein.
Obendrein kam dann noch diese Entscheidung, dass auch noch alle verfügbaren
Leopard 1 Panzer geliefert werden dürfen, fand ich ja sehr interessant.
Und da war dann schnell von einer dreistelligen Zahl die Rede,
die es sicherlich auch noch gibt in gewisser Hinsicht.
Viele Länder haben Leopard 1 Panzer gekauft, aber viele Länder haben auch Leopard
1 Panzer wieder verkauft.
Also ich glaube, Dänemark alleine hatte irgendwie eine große zweistellige Zahl,
die sie komplett an irgendeine norddeutsche Firma verkauft haben für irgendwie
10.000 Euro das Stück, nach dem Motto, wir wollen jetzt einfach mal nur los werden.
Die haben die dann eingelagert und jetzt werden die eben von diesem Unternehmen
wieder zurück gekauft, allerdings in überarbeiteter Form.
Sprich, diese Unternehmen, das ist alles so für Firmen gibt.
Gebraucht Panzerhandel. Ja, genau. Wir haben jetzt hier mal 20,
30 Jahre lang irgendwie Panzer in der Halle gehabt.
Da waren die so halbwegs klimatisiert, irgendwie nicht zu viel kosten,
aber sicherlich auch nicht keine.
Und jetzt sind sie zumindest nicht komplett durchgerostet, aber natürlich sind
die so nicht betriebsfähig.
Das heißt eigentlich muss jeder Panzer nochmal komplett auseinander genommen
werden und wieder neu zusammengesetzt werden.
Was alles für Verschleißteile sind, die Gummi, die dann einfach nicht mehr halten.
Alles muss ja irgendwie auch neu geschmiert werden und wenn da irgendwie in
den Tanks noch irgendwie altes Zeug drin ist, das muss alles gereinigt werden.
Also der Aufwand so ein Panzer wieder in Stand zu setzen, der ist jetzt nicht
gering, aber der Aufwand so einen alten Panzer in Stand zu setzen im Vergleich
zu einem neuen zu bauen, das ist natürlich was ganz anderes.
Vorbehalte muss man immer haben, wenn es um Elektronik geht,
so dass man das dann überhaupt noch kriegt in der Form.
Das mag jetzt bei diesen alten Leos auch nicht so das große Problem sein,
aber sicherlich gibt es Teile, die ja heuer in Demand sind, als sie jetzt noch
irgendwo vorrätig sind.
Das muss man sehen, wie sich das dann löst.
Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, alle Restbestände von Leopard 1 Panzern in Europa,
die es noch irgendwo gibt und die noch in irgendeiner Form wieder in Betrieb
gesetzt werden können, werden im Laufe dieses Jahres und vielleicht noch des
nächsten Jahres an die Ukraine geliefert werden.
Das sind jetzt nicht die modernsten Panzer, aber im Vergleich zu dem,
was sie derzeit aus russischer Produktion oder aus syrwitischer Zeit,
ist es mindestens vergleichbar wenig sogar auch noch besser als das.
Ja, und dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, kann man genug Munition dafür liefern etc.
Du hast dir das auch noch mal genauer angeschaut, ne?
Ja, wir hatten beim letzten Mal so gemutmaßt,
wie denn die Situation aussieht mit der Lieferbarkeit, aber auch wie viel Panzer
denn überhaupt Deutschland produzieren kann.
So und das war so ein bisschen unklar, weil die Produktionszahlen aus den letzten
Jahren eben sehr niedrig zu sein schienen.
Jetzt hat sich Kraus-Mafai Wegmann dazu geäußert, wie das aussieht.
Und zwar laut deren Angaben sind deren Kapazitäten im Moment,
dass sie 50 Panzer neu bauen können pro Jahr,
ungefähr 70 modernisieren können,
also auf, was weiß ich, von A4 auf A6 oder A7, von A4 auf A7 oder A5 auf A7
modernisieren können und ungefähr 50 instand setzen.
Also dann nicht groß modernisieren, sondern einfach nur,
naja, wieder fit machen auf dem Modernisierungsstand,
in dem sie sich befinden und sagten, sie könnten, sagen sie, auf 300 pro Jahr oder
25 pro Monat innerhalb von ein bis zwei Jahren steigern, hochfahren die Produktion.
Und man könnte sogar auch, meinte, auch eine zweite, vielleicht auch eine dritte
Produktionslinie aufbauen.
Das würde dann zwei Jahre dauern plus ein Jahr zum Hochfahren,
aber man könnte jetzt nicht zehn oder fünfzehn Produktionslinien neu hochfahren.
Das wäre wohl auch nicht möglich. Ja und im Kalten Krieg waren die Produktionszahlen
bis zu 40 im Monat oder 400 bis 500 pro Jahr in Hochzeiten.
Das Ganze gilt aber nur, wenn man eben jetzt sofort den Auftrag dazu erteilt,
weil wie das dann funktioniert ist, wenn man jetzt den Auftrag erteilt,
dann gehen halt sofort die Aufträge an eben auch Lieferanten raus,
die dann anfangen so die Motoren zu produzieren und die Elektronik und die Chips zu beschaffen.
Und das macht ja nicht alles Kraus, Mafai, Wiegmann in-house.
Und so dass man dann, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, jetzt fahren wir die Produktion
hoch, gehen die Bestellungen raus.
Und in einem Jahr oder so ist dann auch die neue Produktionseinrichtung dann
fertig und fängt dann eben an zu produzieren und fährt dann innerhalb von einem
Jahr ihre Produktion dann aufs Maximum hoch.
Das heißt, das sind so die Zeiträume, von denen wir reden.
Also sagen ein Jahr, um ja hoch, um anzufangen, um anzufangen,
die Produktion dann dann richtig hochzufahren.
Also machbar wäre das Ganze, aber es gibt eben die Aufträge noch nicht.
Und solange es den Auftrag nicht gibt, können sie auch nicht anfangen,
so Panzer zu produzieren, abgesehen davon, dass sie das Risiko jetzt nicht nicht
eingehen würden und sagen Okay, wir bestellen jetzt mal Teile auf Verdacht so
für eine Milliarde oder so.
Und dann hoffen, dass uns die auch abgekauft werden, sondern der Bau von Panzern
bedarf eben einer Genehmigung nach Kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz.
Das heißt, mit anderen Worten, die brauchen halt den Auftrag und die Genehmigung
überhaupt damit anfangen zu können. und die ist halt noch nicht da.
So stellt sich gerade die Situation da. Und sagt die USA, da hat sich jetzt
nicht großartig viel geändert.
Da sieht es immer noch so aus, dass die jetzt über die nächsten zwölf Monate wohl zwischen 40,
30 bis 40 Panzer ungefähr für die Ukraine,
also Abrams, neu bauen werden,
wobei das mit dem Neubauen auch immer so eine Sache ist,
da differenzieren die Hersteller teilweise nicht zwischen so ganz klar,
ob es jetzt auch ein Neubau ist, wenn sie irgendwie zum Beispiel einen Turm
von einem alten Panzer nehmen oder da einige Alteile einbauen oder überholte Teile.
Es ist dann, also teilweise schlagen die das dann der Neuproduktion zu,
obwohl nicht alle Teile nagelneu hergestellt worden sind. Da muss man also immer
ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ja, also dieser duale Weg da mit Abrams-Panzern und Deoparden,
ich weiß nicht, also aus Sicht der Ukraine macht das natürlich nur so begrenzt
Sinn Abrams-Panzer überhaupt zum Einsatz zu bringen, auch wenn sie am Ende glücklich
über alles sind, was in irgendeiner Form überhaupt geliefert werden kann.
Jetzt ist natürlich so, dass Polen immerhin einer der engsten Verbündeten der
Ukraine ohnehin auf USA-Waffentechnik setzt und die Deutschen da im Wesentlichen ignoriert.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob das daran lag, dass sie das nie haben wollten
oder dass die Deutschen ihnen nichts geben wollten oder was da sozusagen der
Hintergrund ist, Tatsache ist Abrams Panzer, das ist etwas was so in Polen durchaus ein Thema ist.
Und dementsprechend gibt es ja dann auch schon Infrastruktur und Erfahrung quasi im Nachbarland.
Auf der anderen Seite sind vom Abrams irgendwie vier bis fünfmal so viele gebaut
worden wie vom Leopard 2.
Und es liegen eben auch sehr viele davon auf Halde.
Und könnten jetzt mal abgesehen von dem Problem mit dem abgereicherten Uran,
was aus zwei Gründen nicht exportiert werden darf, aber das lässt sich wohl auch austauschen.
Das ist wohl nicht jetzt tief eingeschweißt, sondern das lässt sich wohl auch umbauen.
Also, ich will sagen, eigentlich ist der Bedarf der Ukraine für Panzer könnte sich,
wenn sich der Krieg jetzt mehrere Jahre fortsetzt und die Russen ihre Produktion hochfahren,
damit die Ukraine gewinnen kann, bräuchte sie in der Größenordnung von 3.000,
bis 5.000 Kampfpanzern.
Da macht dann wieder Abrams eine ganze Menge Sinn.
Von der Logistik her, würde ich sagen, sind beide erstmal ein Problem.
Aber auch in den geringen Stückzahlen, in denen die erstmal kommen,
lässt sich das alles handeln, glaube ich.
Glaube ich. Also das ist, ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt mit Abrams oder mit Leopard,
nicht nicht klar kommen würden.
Nee, ich meine die kommen, glaube ich, sowieso mit allem klar.
Das hat das Land ja jetzt auch schon bewiesen und das Militär ist in der Lage sind,
einfach da mit verschiedensten Systemen umzugehen, was normalerweise eigentlich
eine totale Zumutung ist, aber bei denen ist halt einfach die Situation,
wir nehmen alles was wir kriegen können und wenn das halt kompliziert ist,
dann ist es halt kompliziert, dann ist das halt so.
Dann lernen wir das eben in irgendeiner Form mit einzubauen und ohnehin Das
haben wir auch schon häufiger festgestellt.
Am Ende dieses Konfliktes wird mit Sicherheit das ukrainische Militär auf jeden
Fall das modernste Militär auf diesem Planeten sein.
Vielleicht mit Einschränkungen noch Israel im Vergleich oder so.
Aber ich glaube, dass wir weit überlegen, was in Europa unterwegs ist.
Und mindestens so auf par mit den Amerikanern, weil die halt einfach Erfahrung,
Ausbildung Und dann eben auch so eine Vielzahl an Waffentechniken haben und
damit eben auch an taktischen Erfahrungen mit diesen ganzen Techniken.
Und wenn dann eben auch noch langfristig dann eine Versorgung mit diesen Systemen gesichert ist,
dann werden sie auch irgendwann einen Punkt erreichen, wo eben die Russen dreimal
drüber nachdenken würden, in irgendeiner Form nochmal gegen vorzugehen.
Aber das liegt noch sehr weit in der Zukunft, aber ich denke,
das ist schon so der Punkt, den wir irgendwann erreichen werden.
Weil ewig wird das so nicht weitergehen können.
Ja, es ist noch ein weiter Weg bis dahin.
Aber auf jeden Fall werden sie sicherlich die Armee sein mit den meisten Kampferfahrungen
und mit den meisten Praxiserfahrungen, was so diverse Waffensysteme angeht. Aber...
Sie sind natürlich schon auch in einer etwas anderen Ausgangsposition oder guckt, wo sie herkommen.
Sie haben halt auch schon besondere Bedingungen, da sie jetzt gerade entwickeln
ihre Streitkräfte nicht in Friedenszeiten, sondern in Kriegszeiten.
Und da kann man bestimmte Dinge, die längerfristig nötig wären,
kann man jetzt auch nicht machen.
Oder andere Dinge machen jetzt einfach keinen Sinn gerade in Kriegszeiten,
die man dann eher in Zufriedenszeiten machen könnte.
Also ja, aber es wird sicherlich irgendwann ja von Erfahrung und zahlenmäßig
und Ausbildung ja ein sehr kampfstarkes Militär sein,
was die Ukraine hat, wenn sie nicht von den Russen überrannt werden.
Ja, kommen wir vielleicht mal so zu dem Gesamtbild irgendwie.
Unterstützung der Ukraine durch den Westen.
Muss man sich ja vor allem erst mal auch fragen, was hätte man eigentlich vorher
vielleicht auch anders machen können und was ist jetzt sozusagen die weitere
Motivation und was was unterfüttert diese Unterstützung.
Ja, ich meine grundsätzlich ist natürlich die Frage,
die jetzt auch wieder hochkommt im Zusammenhang mit wie viel Friedensanstrengungen unternimmt man immer,
wie auch immer die aussehen mögen, ist natürlich auch die Frage,
so hätte der Westen,
hätten wir irgendwie was anders machen können,
um den Krieg zu verhindern, weil feststellen, der Krieg ist schon eine extreme
Katastrophe, auch für die Ukraine, für Russland und für die Welt.
Also es ist jetzt nichts Tolles und auch wenn die Ukraine gewinnt,
wäre es, glaube ich, besser gewesen, wenn es möglich gewesen wäre,
diesen Krieg irgendwie zu vermeiden.
Da ist natürlich die große Frage, was hätte man anders machen können.
Da kann man jetzt die These aufstellen, man hätte vielleicht härter gegenüber Russland sein sollen,
damit die Abschreckung funktioniert, also die Ukraine vielleicht früher auch
besser bewaffnen, damit Russland das Gefühl hat, das wird nichts, das klappt nicht.
Oder eben umgekehrt, mal netter zu Russland sein können. Also
dass ich Russland irgendwie in die NATO oder in die EU aufnehmen vor vielen
Jahren oder in die Ukraine überlassen als Einflusssphäre und sich einfach nicht
einmischen dort. Wobei...
Man die Frage, in welchem Umfang gab es denn überhaupt Einmischung eigentlich durch den Westen?
Und es gibt in dem Zusammenhang, finde ich,
einen sehr schönen Blick, was denn jetzt die Wurzeln tatsächlich dieses Konflikt
sind, wie es denn eigentlich dazu gekommen ist.
Und die These sieht ungefähr so aus.
Im Grunde genommen haben jetzt Russland und die Ukraine nach dem Zusammenbruch
der Sowjetunion Beide haben keinen guten Weg eingeschlagen,
was so Korruption und Institutionen angeht.
Das haben andere ehemalige Ostblockländer besser geschafft, also allen voran
Tschechien vielleicht, die es geschafft haben zu verhindern,
dass dort eine mächtige Oligarchie entsteht.
Auch wenn sie ein paar Oligarchen dort haben,
sind die Tschechen schon eben konsequenter gegen organisiertes Verbrechen vorgegangen
in den 90ern und haben dann schon verhindert, dass der Staat jetzt in die Hände von Kriminellen fällt.
Das ist weder in der Sowjetunion noch in der Ukraine in den 90ern gelungen,
sondern im Gegenteil, ja unter Yeltsin oder auch dann unter Janukowitsch oder
in anderen Regimen in der Ukraine wurde halt...
Wurde halt eine Oligarchie etabliert. Als Putin dann kam in Russland,
hat Putin quasi die Oligarchen an die Kette gelegt, wenn man so will,
oder sie mit ins Boot geholt gegen 15,
% ihres Geldes oder ihrer Einnahmen, die sie dann an Putin und den Staat abliefern mussten.
In der Ukraine ist es nicht passiert.
In der Ukraine waren weiter die Oligarchen am Ruder, kann man sagen.
Und dann gab es aber eben in der Ukraine einen Konflikt zwischen Oligarchen und Bevölkerung.
Und während in Russland eben Putin die Oligarchie ausgeschaltet hat,
kam es in der Ukraine, ja,
es ist nicht passiert, kam dann eben zu Auseinandersetzungen und am Ende,
ja, hat, Man kann sagen, hat die Oligarchie gegenüber dem Volk oder den Massen
mehr oder weniger, wenn ich sagen, den Kürzeren gezogen.
Aber da ist dieser Konflikt dann aufgetreten, der dann dazu geführt hat.
Russland und Ukraine einfach auf unterschiedlichen Bahnen unterwegs waren.
Und diese unterschiedlichen Bahnen, auf die sie dann unterwegs waren,
haben dann letztlich zum Krieg geführt,
weil eben auch die Ukraine dann einfach einen Gegenentwurf zum russischen System
dargestellt hat oder darstellt.
Weil umgekehrt diese ganzen Sicherheitsbedenken, dass die Ukraine denn jetzt
in Russland einmarschieren würde oder die NATO in Russland einmarschieren würde
oder so. Das ist glaube ich alles kompletter Quatsch oder Hirngespinste einfach.
Also von die Gefahr für Russ,
es gab keine Gefahr auch für Russland, sondern es bestand halt eben nur Gefahr
für das System, für das herrschende Putin-System in Russland,
die von der Ukraine aus...
Ja, mehr so ein ideologischer, mentaler Einmarsch.
Genau, dass sagen plötzlich die Russen, sie könnten sagen, man braucht jetzt
nicht unbedingt einen autokratischen Herrscher um die Oligarchen im Griff zu halten,
sondern eigentlich ist besser, wenn man halt Institutionen hat wie ein funktionierendes
Rechtssystem und wie ein funktionierendes Parlament und eine funktionierende
Regierung und ein funktionierendes Steuersystem und Korruptionsbekämpfung.
Dass vielleicht der bessere Weg ist als...
Als Autokraten sich zu holen, um die Oligarchen zu kontrollieren.
Man macht das besser lieber doch selber.
Das westliche Modell als Bedrohung?
Ja, kann man so ein bisschen sagen.
Beziehungsweise einfach eine Gefährdung der bestehenden Machtstrukturen.
Es ist jetzt auch nicht gesagt,
dass es jetzt so dann auch in Russland funktionieren würde ohne weiteres,
aber nichtsdestotrotz, das ist, glaube ich, warum sich Russland und die Ukraine
plötzlich auf verschiedenen Trajektorien wiedergefunden haben,
die dann am Ende zu dem Einmarsch geführt haben.
Am Ende, was das natürlich bedeutete, war dann auch konkret für die Ukraine,
dass man sich dann natürlich am Westen orientieren musste.
Nicht weil man jetzt den Westen unbedingt so toll findet oder weil das jetzt
alles das ideal ist, aber so die
russische Situation mit einem Autokraten wollte man dann einfach nicht.
Und da gab es dann halt auch nicht so viele Alternativen, was man da machen
konnte, außer sich dann Richtung Westen zu orientieren.
Und vor dem Hintergrund kann man sagen, es hätte wohl nicht geholfen,
jetzt irgendwie netter zu sein.
Ich habe auch nochmal in euch angeguckt, wie viele diplomatische Initiativen
es eigentlich gab, kurz vor dem Einmarsch.
Also gerade Macron hat sich ja ins Zeug gelegt und Scholz auch.
Biden hat seinen Geheimdienstchef geschickt und da war ja nicht so,
dass man jetzt gesagt hätte, irgendwie, mach mal Russland.
Sondern, nee, da war wirklich viel ernsthaftes Bemühen einfach auch da,
dass es nicht dazu kommt und auch
zu signalisieren, Russen, wenn es dazu kommt, dann wird das nicht gut.
So eigentlich war Russland gewarnt, wenn man so will.
Und insofern wäre vielleicht das Einzige, was man jetzt anders hätte machen können,
aus meiner Sicht, war, die Ukraine früher oder schneller zu bewaffnen oder sie
einfach in die NATO aufzunehmen.
Hätte man sie in die NATO aufgenommen, 2010 oder so, hätten wir wahrscheinlich
den Krieg auch nicht gehabt.
Und ein Grund dafür, warum man sie nicht aufgenommen hat, war unter anderem,
weil Deutschland dagegen war, gesagt hat, das kommt überhaupt nicht in die Tüte. So und ja.
Oder eben entsprechend die Ukraine, selbst wenn sie nicht aufgenommen hätte,
so offensichtlich aufzurüsten oder die Sicherheitsgarantien so explizit zu machen,
dass man gesagt hätte, dass die USA und England beispielsweise ja im Budapester-Memorandum
die territoriale Integrität garantiert haben,
hätten einfach öffentlich erklären können,
dass wenn ihr jetzt in Russland einmarschiert, dann werden wir militärisch intervenieren,
weil wir haben ja mal unterschrieben, Ukraine gibt die Atomwaffen ab, dafür beschützen.
Sie dafür garantieren wird die territoriale Integrität.
Auch schon mal, dass wahrscheinlich die Ukraine damals den Fehler gemacht hat
und ihre Atomwaffen zu billig verkauft hat.
Also sie hätte damals wahrscheinlich einfach härtere Garantien einfordern müssen,
Artikel 5-mäßig, im Motto, Angriff auf die Ukraine ist dann auch ein Angriff
auf die USA und Großbritannien und wird entsprechend beantwortet.
Und auf Unruhsland hätten sie ja noch einnehmen können, das ist aber nicht passiert.
Ja, und in dem Zusammenhang, wenn man jetzt dann auf die aktuelle Situation geht,
was es jetzt, nachdem jetzt das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen ist,
kristallisierten sich dann ja drei Möglichkeiten raus für den Westen, was man denn da tun kann.
Und die drei Möglichkeiten groß waren, okay, man hält sich raus,
man unterstützt irgendwie, weil man macht im Prinzip dasselbe wie nach 2014
nach der Kriminvasion, also macht dann du du du, böse böses russland und.
Oder ja das was passiert ist, dass man die
ukraine moralisch materiell und mit waffen unterstützt so in einem bestimmten
ausmaß oder die dritte Variante wäre der Ukraine jetzt einfach zum Sieg zu verhelfen.
Allen was möglich ist.
Also, oder so rum, Variante 2 ist eben,
Ukraine so viel zu liefern, dass sie nicht verliert und Variante 3 ist,
der Ukraine alles zu liefern, was sie braucht, zu gewinnen.
Und darunter würden natürlich Waffensysteme fallen,
Waffenunterstützung, aber auch bis hin natürlich zur Intervention mit eigenen
Systemen, mit eigenen Waffensystemen, vielleicht sogar mit eigenen Soldaten.
So was, aber natürlich niemand wegen Angst vor Dritter Weltkrieg oder so eigentlich haben wollte.
Aber schaut man sich jetzt dann vergangene Konflikte an wie Vietnam,
da sind die USA halt auch mit Truppen reingegangen und das war irgendwie… also ist jetzt nicht so,
dass, sagen wir, der Ausschluss,
dass da die NATO selber jetzt militärisch drauf antwortet oder in dem Fall erstmal
die USA und England nicht militärisch eigene Truppen einsetzen,
war schon ein Stück weit Zurückhaltung oder Rückzieher.
Also ich denke ja nicht, dass Vietnam jetzt ein besonders brillantes Beispiel
ist, wie man es machen sollte.
Nee, sicherlich nicht, wie man es machen sollte, aber eben mit welchem, also was eben auch geht,
Man meint, wir haben ja sogar für die dann in Vietnam, ist die USA um eine halbe
Million Soldaten reingegangen und musste halt auch eine Wehrpflicht ausrufen,
um überhaupt genug Soldaten zu haben.
Das war natürlich ein Riesending.
Ich erwähne es halt nur, weil das jetzt auch nicht außerhalb des Spektrums jetzt
des Denkbaren oder Möglichen gewesen wäre,
sondern eigentlich eher, wenn man jetzt tatsächlich internationale Verträge
und so wirklich konsequent hätte hochhalten wollen,
hätte man militärisch, also hätten die USA und Großbritannien eigene Truppen
schicken müssen, um der Ukraine zu helfen.
Stattdessen hat man sich dann jetzt darauf verlegt, aus meiner Sicht erst mal
so viel zu liefern, dass die Ukraine nicht verliert.
Aber sich noch nicht dazu hat durchringen können, die Unterstützung soweit auszuweiten,
dass sie jetzt sehr schnell gewinnt.
Obwohl das noch mal rein physikalisch, wirtschaftlich der Macht der USA und des Westens.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht auch im ökonomischen Interesse.
Ja, ja. Wobei jetzt, das war eine interessante These jetzt aber von Zayhan,
wenn du dir diese drei Varianten anguckst. Zayhan?
Seyhan?
Ja, ist so ein Geopolitiker, der eine Reihe von Büchern auch geschrieben hat.
Wie heißt er genau?
Peter Seyhan. Ja.
Und der hat jetzt die Theorie aufgestellt, dass der Westen die Form der Unterstützung
für die Ukraine gewählt hat,
die er gewählt hat, deswegen gewählt hat, um die Gefahr eines Atomkriegs zu reduzieren.
Also die These ist so ein bisschen, wenn man die Ukraine alleine gelassen hätte
und Russland Erfolg gehabt hätte mit der Besetzung der Ukraine,
dass dann zwangsläufig eben im nächsten
Schritt andere ehemalige Sowjetrepubliken und unter anderem das Baltikum oder
Polen gehörte ja auch mal irgendwann zum Russischen Reich und Finnland auch
und diverse andere Gegenden auch mal da werden.
Und dass man sich sicher war, dass wenn man jetzt Russland in der Ukraine gewähren
lässt, dass es dann eben im nächsten Punkt dann zu einer Eskalation kommt,
die dann in einem Atomkrieg endet.
Also sprich, wir müssen die Ukraine unterstützen, damit es nicht zum Atomkrieg
kommt oder um die Gefahren des Atomkriegs langfristig zu reduzieren. Aber...
Umgekehrt herrscht dann auch die Angst, wenn wir es jetzt zu viel machen,
wenn wir Russland jetzt zu sehr und zu schnell schlagen und zu viel unterstützen,
dann steigt eben die Möglichkeit einer Eskalation und eines Atomkriegs auch.
Das heißt, der Westen versucht sich quasi mit der Unterstützung auf einem Korridor durch zu balancieren,
wo das Eskalationsrisiko insgesamt am niedrigsten ist. So könnte man das vielleicht zusammenfassen.
Ich finde, das hat durchaus was für sich.
Diese Überlegung ist natürlich nicht ideal für die Ukraine, kann man auch sagen.
Und es ist auch so, dass aber in beiden Fällen, wo die Gefahr einer Eskalation
höher ist, man nicht sagen kann, und dann kommt es mit Sicherheit zum Atomkrieg.
Also weder sagen, wenn man die Ukraine Russland überlassen würde,
käme es zwangsläufig dann zum Atomkrieg ist genauso falsch,
wie wenn wir der Ukraine jetzt auch noch U-Boote und Flugzeugträger liefern,
dann kommt es zum Atomkrieg.
Beides stimmt halt nicht, aber die Gefahr steigt halt.
Und ich denke, da ist durchaus was dran an dieser Einschätzung.
Ist jetzt nicht völlig irrational, würde ich sagen.
Und am Ende ist so die Frage, worum geht es denn jetzt am Ende eigentlich in
diesem ganzen Konflikt?
Geht es jetzt um Territorium? Geht es jetzt um Einflusssphären?
Geht es um Sicherheit?
Geht es um Zugang zu Rohstoffen?
Oder geht es um verschiedene Ideologien, die da jetzt gerade aufeinandertreffen?
In dem Zusammenhang sind ja jetzt auch wieder diverse Friedensaktivisten auf den Plan getreten,
die sich gegen eine weitere oder vermehrte Unterstützung der Ukraine mit Waffen ausgesprochen haben,
Ich meine, man müsste jetzt irgendwie auf die Ukraine Einfluss nehmen,
um da Boden abzugeben und Russland zu versöhnen.
Weiß der Geier, wie Sie sich das jetzt genau vorstellen? Aber letztlich, ja.
Irgendwie ist jetzt gut mit verteidigen jetzt ist als
doch mal still irgendwie es haltet doch die andere wange
hin genau und Und
das interessante bisschen ist oder
Also mein mein eindruck
ist dass gerade auch ein bisschen in den Konflikt wir zwischen Realismus und
Realpolitik auf der einen Seite und auch Idealismus auf der anderen Seite sehen.
Der Kalte Krieg war speziell auf amerikanischer Seite bis Reagan gekommen ist,
eben sehr von Realpolitik bzw.
Politischem Realismus geprägt, wo man gesagt hat, es gibt
halt nun mal die Sowjetunion und die wird es immer geben
und die ist ein großes Reich und es gibt die USA und die wird es auch irgendwie
immer geben und die ist ein großes Reich und der Rest der Welt sind mehr oder
weniger die Pokerchips oder Einflusssphären dieser beiden Großmächte in dieser bipolaren Welt.
Und man hält sich aus der Kerneinflussphäre des anderen raus.
Also sprich, wenn die Russen oder wenn die Sowjets sich entscheiden,
in Ungarn oder in Tschechien einzumarschieren, wie es damals war,
um dort Regime-Change zu machen, dann ist das mehr oder weniger deren innere Angelegenheit.
Da mischen wir uns jetzt nicht ein und eben umgekehrt auch nicht.
Und Europa ist im Prinzip so so ein Spielball.
Also alle kleinen Länder sind grundsätzlich nur Chips in diesem Pokerspiel der Großmächte.
Und auf dieser Sicht der Welt basiert jetzt irrerweise gerade auch Sicht auf
den Russlandkonflikt durch viele,
sage ich eher Linke, die,
jetzt...
Diese Sicht übernehmen, die sagt, ja, große Länder,
Großmächte haben nun mal das Recht um sich herum,
eine Einflusssphäre oder sich die Welt aufzuteilen und darin dann zu wirken
und zu walten, wie auch immer es ihnen genehm ist.
Und ja, nur das ist halt eine sehr amerikanische Sicht von Leuten wie Kissinger,
wie Nixon und wo eben idealistische Werte oder Menschenrechte spielen keine
Rolle, sondern es geht eben nur um Interessen.
So um machtpolitische Interessen und alles andere hat sich dem unterzuordnen
und kleine Länder haben eigentlich nichts zu melden in der Welt.
Wenn du das Großmacht oder du tust, was irgendwie die Großmacht sagt im Wesentlichen.
So funktioniert die Welt.
Das war halt, und wenn man jetzt eben die Sicht vertritt,
dass Russland irgendwie einen Anspruch darauf hat,
bei der sich in die Politik seiner Nachbarn einzumischen, dann hängt man eben
dieser Weltsicht an, dass kleine Länder keine Rechte haben in dieser Welt.
Und sich eben unterzuordnen haben.
Und diese realpolitische Sicht der Welt für einen kalten Krieg oder für die
Zeit nach dem Kalten Krieg, war das wahrscheinlich auch eine angemessene Sicht
der Dinge, das war eben die Realität.
Allerdings ist das dann... ja...
Mit Antritt von Ronald Reagan als Präsident in den 80ern.
Dann, also erstens war Reagan kein Realpolitiker, kein politischer Realist,
sondern ein Idealist, ein christlicher Spinner, aber jedenfalls kein Realist.
Und hat halt gesagt, was interessiert mich die Einflusssphäre der Sowjetunion. Ich...
Ja, die sind der Hort des Bösen und wir machen die jetzt platt.
Wie auch immer wir das können.
Das war das eine Ding und es ist auch irgendwie mehr oder weniger gelungen.
Also die Sowjetunion hat sich vermutlich eher aus anderen Gründen zusammengefaltet,
aber man hat halt auch einfach ganz klar gesagt, ja.
Und dann das nächste Ding war, wo einfach die realpolitische oder der politische
Realismus einfach komplett versagt hat, war, als dann der Islamismus aufgetreten ist.
Weil, wenn du so was wie Islamismus hast plötzlich,
dann ist die Theorie, dass souveräne Nationalstaaten sich in einem permanenten
Überlebenskampf befinden, völlig nutzlos, weil sowas wie Islamismus,
da spielt das Konzept von Nationalstaaten überhaupt keine Rolle.
Das ist halt auch eine idealistische Sicht und mit politischem Realismus kommt
man da halt nicht wirklich weiter oder ist man da nicht wirklich weiter gekommen.
Deswegen hat man sich dann auch teilweise so komplett verzettelt.
So mein Punkt, wie mir das klar geworden ist, ist,
Dass jetzt, wie gesagt, plötzlich so Leute, ja, Linke,
wie jetzt, ja,
wer hat sich da jetzt gerade vorgetan, wie die sagen, mag ich nicht oder so,
ja, dass die eigentlich einer Ideologie,
dass das Wort Reden, die auch von Henry Kissinger oder von Nixon oder so hätte
stammen können und eine Sicht auf die Dinge ist,
wie sie in den 50er und 60er Jahren entstanden ist und die eigentlich komplett
obsolet geworden ist, aber offensichtlich denn immer noch bis heute durch die Köpfe geistert.
Ich kann diese Position, ich muss sagen, ich habe wirklich extreme Schwierigkeiten,
die auch nur nachvollziehen zu können, wie man denn dahin gelangt.
Also das eint uns, glaube ich, in der Sicht auf diesen Konflikt.
Für uns ist die Lage irgendwie klar. Also wir sehen da irgendwie einen offensichtlichen
Aggressor und wir sehen ein Land in Not. Wir sehen, dass,
tagtäglich nahezu alle völkerrechtlichen Grundsätze verletzt werden durch Russland.
Bleibt wenig übrig, was nicht verletzt wurde und das macht die Sache irgendwie
auch klar und selbstverständlich muss so ein Land die Möglichkeit haben sich zu verteidigen.
Was sollen sie denn sonst tun? Sollen sie irgendwie einfach sagen,
ja die Linken wollen Frieden haben, dann lassen wir uns doch einfach umbringen.
Also wie kann man überhaupt nur an diesen Punkt gelangen und ich frage mich,
was ist eigentlich deren Idee, wie sich denn irgendetwas dadurch verbessern soll?
Die Grundidee ist halt, die da rumgeistert ist halt sozusagen dieser politischer
Realismus bzw. der wird dann in What about-ismus, aber die USA.
Haben schließlich auch überall interveniert und sind irgendwie einmarschiert
in anderen Ländern wie im Irak beispielsweise,
in Afghanistan und so sind große Länder nun mal.
Nur was Leute halt übersehen dann an der Stelle ist,
nur weil die USA was macht, heißt dass nicht, dass das richtig ist und dass
dadurch dann jetzt die Sowjets das Recht bekommen, das auch zu tun.
Also unrecht das einen legitimiert nicht, unrecht das anderen.
Und ich kann mich auch nicht erinnern, dass Sarah Wagenknecht jetzt irgendwie für den Irakkrieg war.
Ne, was heißt nicht für den, sondern die sehen natürlich die andere Seite des Bildes nicht.
Wenn du eine Invasion verteidigst, indem du sagst,
ja, aber da gab es ja auch eine Invasion, Abgesehen davon, dass dann durchaus
auch die Situation eine gänzlich andere war, aber selbst weil jetzt einfach nur sagt, Invasion so.
Man kann das einfach nicht rechtfertigen und auch nicht mit irgendwelchem etwaigen
Fehlverhalten der der usa oder anderen dingen sondern.
Am Ende denke ich, dass die richtige und vernünftige Sicht auf die Welt ist.
Das ist nicht Realpolitik, sondern wie es so schön heißt, Institutenökonomik
meiner Meinung nach. Nämlich, dass Geschichte von inneren Prozessen entschieden
wird, auch in einem Land.
Außenpolitik spielt auch eine Rolle, aber während in der Realpolitik die Länder
quasi Black Boxes sind und es nicht interessiert,
was in dem Land passiert, sondern dass eben das Außenverhältnis von dem,
was im Inneren passiert, unberührt ist, was natürlich offensichtlich so Quatsch
ist, das ist nicht so in der Realität.
Aber tatsächlich, ich meine auch der Unterschied jetzt zwischen Ukraine und Russland,
diese Auseinanderentwicklung ist dadurch entstanden, dass sich Institutionen
anders entwickelt haben und andere Macht bekommen haben.
Und am Ende des Tages, glaube ich, entscheidet, und da war vorhin das Beispiel
mit Tschechien, warum sich auch Tschechien anders entwickelt hat als Ungarn.
Wo eben man in Ungarn, also die ganzen organisierten Kriminellen,
die halt aus Tschechien vertrieben worden sind, so russische Mafia haben sich
dann in Ungarn angesiedelt, beispielsweise.
Und das hat jetzt mit Außenpolitik nichts zu tun. Aber...
Hat dann am Ende, also das, was schon letztlich im Innern eines Landes passiert,
also auch die Ideen oder die vorherrschende Meinung, die eigene Identität,
die man hat, wirkt, glaube ich,
am Ende viel größer oder hat viel größeren Einfluss auf das,
was am Ende außenpolitisch passiert und welche,
wie viel Macht ein Land dann hat und entwickelt am Ende des Tages auch auf der
Welt oder welche Position ein Land auf der Welt einnimmt,
hängt mehr von dem ab, was im Innern des Landes passiert und nicht,
wie es sich nach außen verhält.
So, könnte man es vielleicht zusammenfassen.
Und diese, ich sag mal, auch rein machiavellische Sichtweise auf Politik ist einfach auch überholt.
Da weiß man heute ein bisschen besser Bescheid.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, manche einfachen Ideen halten sich halt auch lange,
weil vielleicht auch was dran ist oder weil eben lange die Welt so funktioniert hat.
Und mir fällt das besonders auf, wenn man jetzt so die oft alte Politikerrie
geredet, egal von wo sie jetzt noch so im Krieg unterwegs waren,
gerade in den USA oder auch in Deutschland.
Dass die eben alle noch eine ganz andere Sicht auf die Welt haben,
eben genau diesen politischen Realismus mit den zwei Blöcken und mit den Einflusssphären.
Mit den kleinen Ländern als Marionetten.
Interessant ist vielleicht noch, dass die EU, also dass die Existenz der EU
an sich auch noch mal so ein kompletter Gegenentwurf zu diesem machtpolitischen Realismus ist,
wo plötzlich souveräne Staaten in Europa gesagt haben,
wir lassen es jetzt mal mit dem Krieg Krieg und stattdessen finden wir uns jetzt
freiwillig zusammen und wir machen jetzt hier nicht die Nummer mit der Hegemonie,
sondern wir versuchen halt hier jetzt so, sagen,
so was Eigenes, Demokratisches unter
Staaten aufzubauen mit viel Recht und Angleichung und allem pipa pro.
Das heißt, die EU ist jedenfalls ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass Dinge zwischen
Staaten und auf der Welt ganz anders funktionieren können als im Kalten Krieg.
Wo man eben gemeinsam ohne einen Chef,
sondern mit, ja, wenn man es in der EU hat,
mit wechselnden Ratspräsidentschaften und mit gewissen Vorteilen für kleine
Länder, dass die auch nicht komplett von den Großen hinten übergeworfen werden können.
Also eigentlich eine sehr, wie ich finde,
nach vorne gerichtete Art,
Außenpolitik zu gestalten oder Beziehungen zu anderen Ländern zu gestalten,
die natürlich sowohl eine Gefahr für die Sowjetunion wie auch für die USA darstellt.
Das muss man vielleicht auch sehen, das war jetzt mit den Amerikanern.
Verbündet sind und auch sicherlich in vielen Dingen näher stehen als den Russen,
aber die USA doch auch für eine andere Art von Monster stehen als das,
was wir gerne hätten so an Staaten.
Weil alle Staaten sind Monster, die halt im Zweifelsfall über Menschen hinwegtrampeln,
wie wir über Käfer oder Ameisen.
Und deswegen willst du eigentlich Staaten haben, die möglichst menschenfreundlich sind.
Und du brauchst aber auch Staaten, eben diese Monster, du brauchst dieses eigene
Monster, um für dein eigenes Auskommen und deine eigene Sicherheit zu sorgen.
Und das Monster muss halt mindestens dieses leisten,
aber sollte abgesehen davon, dass es dann nach außen hin für Sicherheit sorgt
und für ihn nach Wohlstand,
sollte es natürlich gleichzeitig auch möglichst menschenfreundlich sein und
eben dem Einzelnen auch möglichst viele Bedürfnisse befriedigen und möglichst
viele Entfaltungsmöglichkeiten geben.
Aspekt kann man sich dann eben auch die Staaten so anschauen,
wie die diese Kriterien erfüllen.
Und ja, die USA schneidet da auch nicht optimal ab in Ländervergleichungen und so,
sondern eigentlich, eigentlich ist jetzt,
wenn man jetzt ideologisch sich anguckt, welche Staaten sind am besten für die Menschen,
dann ist relativ klar, dass das skandinavische Modell das menschenfreundlichste
ist auf der Welt und nicht das amerikanische und vielleicht nicht das russische
und auch nicht das chinesische Modell.
Ein ähnliches neues Modell, was ja auch diskutiert wird im Kontext des ganzen
Ukraine-Konflikts, ist, wie die Ukraine selbst sich jetzt positioniert und auftritt.
Denn die ganze Strategie von Zelensky war ja nun von Anfang an ganz klar auf
genau diese Aspekte der Demokratie zu setzen und mittlerweile wird so dieser
Begriff des Neo-Idealismus durch die Diskussion getrieben.
Also das sozusagen das Vorgehen der Ukraine eben ganz klar auf sozusagen die
Rückbesinnung auf die eigentlichen Werte geprägt ist und dass man sozusagen
so dieses Demokratie als wehrhaftes Ding,
was gut für die Menschen ist, dass man das eben damit neu belebt.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein Grund dafür, dass seinen Verben.
Um die Unterstützung der Ukraine so erfolgreich ist.
Ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass jetzt eben das Ganze frei wäre von Einflusssphäre
und von Machtinteressen Europas.
Klar, wir sehen uns jetzt in der Sicherheit bedroht, gerade auch,
weil die Ukraine geopolitisch natürlich eine Rolle spielt, also wo es gelegen
ist, aber eben auch was so die Ressourcen betrifft, Getreideproduktion etc.
Ist auch ein Hightech-Land, das ist durchaus auch ein Land mit Potenzial.
Also es ist nah an uns dran und von daher sollte das uns ja auch alles nicht
egal sein. Aber es gibt, sagen wir mal, Länder, die ähnlich gelagert sind,
die uns sehr viel egaler sind.
Sagen wir mal, weiß Russland zum Beispiel, was noch weniger irgendeine Rolle
spielt in unserer Debatte, weil wir es natürlich auch noch sehr viel mehr als
Lost Case betrachten und die Ukraine mehr.
Da hat er immer so ein bisschen zwischen, ja, ist das jetzt irgendwie schon Russland?
Ja, also ich glaube, das hat mir auch ganz am Anfang thematisiert,
so dass wir gerade so mit einer westlichen Brille auch überhaupt gar kein Bild
haben von der Ukraine, dass wir das nicht trennen konnten, dass wir das nicht
unterscheiden konnten, dass wir nicht wussten, ist das jetzt irgendwie ja,
ist das jetzt irgendwie so wird oder nicht oder wie oder so.
All das, was wir jetzt gelernt haben im letzten Jahr über das Land.
Das ist glaube ich etwas, was einfach völlig unterrepräsentiert war als allgemein
Wissen und das bessert sich jetzt ein wenig.
Aber es hat eben dann auch viel mit diesem Werben zu tun und es war eben auch
deshalb so erfolgreich, weil die Ukraine ja auch ein Ideal mit im Angebot hat.
Es ist nicht nur so ein Hilf uns, wir haben aber Weizen und wir sind aber wichtig
und Wir sind ja hier irgendwie der Keil zwischen euch und Russland,
spielt alles eine Rolle. Aber ich denke, sehr viel wichtiger ist dieses ganz.
Klare Zeigen, offene Gesellschaft, Solidarität, demokratische Prinzipien,
Antikorruption, Rechtsstaat, das ist all so, das wollen wir haben,
wir wollen das Beste von euch kopieren und das wollen wir sozusagen hier zum Laufen bringen.
So ein ganz starker Punkt in dieser ganzen Geschichte und von diesem Begriff
Neoidarialismus, der jetzt hier sozusagen dafür für dieses Verhalten verwendet
wird, fand ich sehr interessant.
Ich mein, was halt, also sagen,
der geopolitische Ausblick auch jetzt so ein bisschen von, so wie ihn auch Zeiharn
formuliert hat, aber steht damit nicht alleine, ist, dass,
jetzt ganz Osteuropa eigentlich neu in den Blickpunkt der europäischen Politik
geraten ist und dass sich die Rolle Osteuropas jetzt ändert.
Ehrlich ist, hat der Westen ja immer so ein bisschen bisschen auf dieses Osteuropa heruntergeschaut.
Demotoro, das ist halt alles ein bisschen, ja, auch wie Ostdeutschland,
die sind halt so ein bisschen wirtschaftlich und überhaupt hinterher jetzt.
Und die müssen jetzt noch erstmal richtig Demokratie lernen und richtig Wirtschaft
und Kapitalismus und unsere schönen Institutionen erst mal kopieren so und dann
dürfen die auch mitreden.
In dem Zusammenhang hat sich halt so ein bisschen als suboptimal erwiesen,
dass man jetzt die EU-Institutionen so mehr oder weniger eins zu eins auf Osteuropa übertragen hat,
weil das passte halt alles nicht ganz so,
weil die EU ist halt designt,
die Institutionen und Prinzipien sind halt für entwickelte Länder,
so wie Deutschland und England und Frankreich und Italien, und die halt ein
moderates Wachstum haben und die relativ ausentwickelt sind.
Und das passte nicht immer alles so auf das, was im Osten sinnvoll war oder
richtig gewesen wäre, weil dort einfach mehr Dynamik und mehr Freiheit herrscht.
Das hat Russland auch teilweise dann genutzt oder auch andere Länder,
die dann nicht in der EU waren, die sich dann einfach ein bisschen dynamischer entwickeln konnten.
Und ja, hätte die EU vielleicht, hätte man ein bisschen mehr im Nachhinein betrachtet
gucken müssen, dass man den besonderen Verhältnissen im Osten mehr Rechnung trägt.
Aber gut, das ist nun mal gelaufen.
Was man jetzt aber sieht, ist, dass Polen sich herauskristallisiert als das Land,
als ist der Kernländer, dass den Gegenpol zu Russland und die.
Verteidigung gegen Russland dann hauptsächlich schultern wird und tragen wird,
genauso dann, wenn die Ukraine mit reinkommt. Also, die Rolle.
Deutschland war ja mal Frontstaat. Es war ja mal der Job von Deutschland,
quasi direkt dem Warschauer Pakt gegenüberzustehen.
Und das ist jetzt nicht mehr unser Job, sondern die Russen müssten halt erst
mal durch Polen durch jetzt, bevor sie uns gefährlich werden könnten.
Es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass das irgendwie in absehbarer Zeit möglich
sein wird, wenn sie irgendwie nicht mal 200 Kilometer oder so in die Ukraine
reinschaffen von ihrer eigenen Grenze aus.
Dann stellt sich natürlich jetzt auch dann die Frage langfristig,
was wird denn dann so die sicherheitspolitische Rolle Deutschlands sein,
wenn wir gar nicht so sehr den Gegenpol da bilden müssen.
Und da ist dann die Sicht, dass es sich langfristig so entwickeln wird, dass,
Deutschland sich mehr den sicherheitspolitischen Interessen Europas in der Welt zuwenden wird.
Also sozusagen gar nicht so sehr gegen Russland, sondern dass wir dann selber
auch uns Flugzeugträger zulegen zum Beispiel und dann halt dann mehr Verantwortung
im Nahen Osten oder in Asien oder auch gegenüber China übernehmen,
weil sagen das mit den Russen, da kümmert sich dann Osteuropa drum.
Gut. So,
jetzt gegen Ende vielleicht noch ein Punkt, weil es ja noch so einen Bericht
gab zum Thema Nord Stream, der ein bisschen Welle gemacht hat und vielleicht
bei manchen Leuten ein Fragezeichen hinterlassen hat.
Bericht von dem Journalisten Seymour Hirsch,
der ja so eine wilde These aufgestellt hat, nämlich das ganze Anschlag,
der auf die Nord Stream Pipelines verübt wurde. UKW berichtete.
Ursache hat, sehr im Westen zu suchen ist, nämlich in den USA. Was ist davon zu halten?
Ja, also genauer gesagt, ich meine vielleicht noch zu Herrsch.
Also Herrsch war übrigens nicht derjenige, der bei Watergate dabei war. Das waren andere.
Aber er hat unter anderem das Massaker von Milai im Vietnamkrieg an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht,
was einen großen Beitrag dazu geleistet hat, dass der Wehrstand in den USA gegen
den Vietnamkrieg stieg.
Und er war auch unter anderem der Erste, der Abu Ghraib, also,
das Foltergefängnis im Irak, wo amerikanische Soldaten sehr unappetitliche Dinge
getan haben, mit Gefangenen auch
ans Tageslicht gebracht hat und generell sich so zum Ziel gesetzt hat,
die Verbrechen der amerikanischen Regierung ans Tageslicht zu bringen.
Genau, und der ist auch ziemlich alt, muss man dazu sagen, also um die 85 oder so.
Ja, ich glaube, er ist jetzt 85 Jahre alt und er hat viele Verdienste,
sicherlich als Journalist, angehäuft.
Aber er ist jetzt kein neutraler Berichterstatter, sondern er ist schon jemand
auch mit einer klaren Mission.
Und ist auch politisch, ja, sagen eher klar links,
und ist aber dann in letzter Zeit damit aufgefallen,
dass er dann doch auch etwas fragwürdige Dinge oder Meinungen vertreten hat,
unter anderem das auch gemutmaßt hat,
dass die Türkei Chemiewaffen in Syrien eingesetzt haben könnte und dass das
ein Volksfleck-Einsatz war und dass die Syrer selber,
der Assad, keine Chemiewaffen eingesetzt hätte und so.
Das war so ein Ding oder eine andere Geschichte.
Über Bin Laden, wo er dann auch meinte, bin Laden hätte seit fünf Jahren längst
in der Gefangenschaft der Pakistaner gelebt und die hätten ihn dann einfach ans Messer geliefert.
Und dieser ganze Raid und so hätte so gar nicht stattgefunden. Und sie hätten ihn...
Also ein paar komische Dinge hat er da verbreitet.
Aber unabhängig davon, kann man sagen,
was, wenn man sich jetzt seine Geschichte anschaut, die zum einen nur auf einer
anonymen Quelle beruht, das sagt er selber, er hat nur eine Quelle.
Und in der Regel, wenn es sowohl bei Geheimdiensten als auch bei Journalisten,
kann man lange Kette aufzählen von Berichten,
die dann nur auf einer Quelle basierten, die sich dann halt als einfach falsch
herausgestellt haben und dann ein Problem waren.
Insofern, die Quellenlage ist schon mal schwierig.
Aber wenn man sich dann noch seine Geschichte anguckt oder durchliest,
findet man auch nicht wirklich viel Substanz.
So sehr viel ist, was ich so ein bisschen als alle Kamellen bezeichnen würde, wo einfach nochmal...
In den letzten 80 Jahren immer wieder mal Dinge erwähnt, die die USA irgendwann
mal im Kalten Krieg hauptsächlich gemacht haben,
die meiner Meinung nach nur so mittelrelevant sind für das, was die Leute tut
oder wo die Situation ganz anders war.
Und er hat auch einfach eine Reihe von faktischen Fehlern drin.
Also Stoltenberg soll dem Artikel nach während der Zeit des Vietnamkriegs für
die CIA spioniert haben.
Allerdings war Stoltenberg damals 16 Jahre alt, das passt also schon mal nicht so richtig.
Dann hat er behauptet, man hätte halt diese Bald-Opps-Militärübung genutzt,
dafür, um die Minen zu legen und hätte deswegen plötzlich Minenräume neu aufgenommen
ins Bald-Opps-Programm,
das aber seit vielen Jahren fester Bestandteil ist. Was ist denn das?
Das ist in der baltischen See eine Militärübung der NATO. Also je, wie es stattfindet.
Die einmal im Jahr stattfindet oder neben verschiedenen NATO-Schiffen dann in
der Ostsee Militärübungen machen.
Da war jetzt nichts. Also er hat behauptet, das sei irgendwie,
sie hätten da jetzt extra dann neue Minenräumenübungen eingeführt,
was halt nachweislich nicht der Fall ist.
Dann hat er was von einem norwegischen Minenräumschiff der Alterklasse gesprochen, was halt nicht da war.
Dann spricht er, dass die Auslösung
der Bomben durch norwegische Boeing Poseidon P8 stattgefunden hat.
Aber die sind zum einen noch nicht im Einsatz. Und dann war auch in dem fraglichen
Zeitraum keine norwegische P8 näher als 1500 Kilometer nah dran an der Pipeline.
Dann gesehen, eine amerikanische P8 war da aber zwei Stunden nachdem die Explosion
registriert worden war.
Ja, die wollten jetzt nur gucken, ob es auch geklappt hat,
aber tatsächlich wussten zu dem Zeitpunkt dann,
waren halt die Seismogramme schon eingegangen und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist
eigentlich eher höher, dass sie dahin geflogen sind, um zu gucken,
was denn da passiert ist eigentlich.
Also sie hätten sonst nicht hinfliegen müssen, wenn sie gewusst hätten,
worum es sich denn handelt.
P8 ist so ein Seeaufklärungsflugzeug von Boeing.
Genau, im Prinzip ist es eine Boeing 737.
Umgerüstet auf Navy-Bedarf.
Die aber speziell ausgerüstet ist eben für, um U-Boote zu suchen, um aufzuklären.
Und die hat halt auch so Einrichtungen, wo man unter anderem Sonarbojen abwerfen kann,
so die dann normalerweise dann unter Wasser scannen, eben den Boden oder eventuell U-Boote suchen.
Und laut der Hirschgeschichte sollen solche Sonarbojen eingesetzt worden sein.
Um dann per akustischem Signal die Sprengsätze auszulösen.
Und der hat sich dann irgendeinen amerikanischen Professor dann noch geholt,
der dann irgendwas erzählt hat von Wignia und schwierig, dass irgendwie das
nicht zufällig ausgelöst wird durch irgendwelche Hintergrundgeräusche und so.
Und dabei ist aber dieses ganze Thema Unterwasserkommunikation nicht nur gut
erforscht, sondern standardisiert.
Also es gibt NATO-Standards dafür und man weiß ungefähr, wie die Reichweiten und so aussehen.
Und ja, also das passt halt auch alles nicht.
Oder die Art von Expertise, die dort erweckt wird, die dieser Professor haben
soll, hat er definitiv offensichtlich nicht. Gut, das war ein emeritierter Professor.
Und für mich aber war halt einfach,
was am wenigsten Sinn machte an der ganzen Geschichte,
dass sich die USA einen anderen Geheimdienst zur Hilfe geholt haben sollen,
nämlich Norwegen, weil sie angeblich selber nicht in der Lage waren,
eine Pipeline zu sprengen, ohne jetzt Norwegen um Hilfe zu fragen.
Und das halte ich für ziemlich an den Haaren herbeigeholt.
Und alles, was ich über die Arbeit von Geheimdiensten weiß, selbst verbündete
Geheimdienste sitzen halt auf ihren Informationen.
Und bei so einer Operation, die so heikel wäre, so willst du auf gar keinen
Fall irgendwie auch noch ausländische Geheimdienste mit da drin haben.
Ja, auch vor allem Norwegen, die einfach so ein bisschen so dieser Inbegriff ist.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das sagen soll, aber das ist irgendwie gerade
nicht so das erste Land, was einem irgendwie einfällt, wenn es darum geht,
irgendwie fremde Infrastruktur zu zerstören.
Genau, und das Motiv soll dann sein für Norwegen, dass sie dann mehr Öl,
mehr Gas verkaufen können.
Die verkaufen jetzt schon alles, was sie produzieren.
Naja, aber ich meine,
es schließt jetzt nicht aus, dass jetzt trotzdem die USA irgendwas gemacht haben,
aber wenn sie es gemacht hätten, erscheint mir das, wie Hirsch es beschreibt, wie sie es gemacht haben.
Sollen, für extrem unwahrscheinlich aus politischen Gründen,
aus Gründen, wie der Geheimdienst arbeitet und auch aus technischen Gründen.
Weil es hätte da bessere Mittel und Wege gegeben, das Ganze auch auszulösen.
Also du kannst beispielsweise, also wenn es mein Job gewesen wäre,
diese Pipeline irgendwie zu sprengen und da eine Zündung zu installieren,
die fern auslösbar ist, ja dann hätte ich halt im Ultra-Langwellen oder Extrem-Langwellen
Bereich entsprechende Empfangstechnik benutzt,
dann hätte man das auch per Satellit oder von den USA aus auslösen können.
Die Technik ist da.
Das sind zwar dann nur wenige Bits, das sind dann, was weiß ich, mit...
2, 3, 5 Bit pro Sekunde oder so läuft diese Funkkommunikation nur ab.
Aber du könntest dafür auch die Pipeline sogar als Langwellenantenne nutzen,
wenn du wolltest, bräuchtest du aber nicht mehr.
Das hätte ich gemacht, weil diese Sonarbojen, die haben halt nur 25 Kilometer
Reichweite und hätte man mehrere abwerfen müssen.
Außerdem hätte wiederum, wenn die, also sie müssen da dann auch schon mit einer
gewissen Energie rein gehen,
damit die jetzt so 25 Kilometer überbrücken können und die ganze Gegend ist
dann halt auch mit Mikrofonen und so voll.
Das heißt, diese Kommunikation wäre dann auch erfasst worden,
wahrscheinlich von Mikrofonen, wenn die das irgendwo über Sonarbojen gemacht hätten.
Ja, insofern macht für mich alles nur nicht so richtig Sinn.
Also mich hat die Geschichte von Hirsch jetzt nicht überzeugt.
Und ich glaube zwar nicht, dass er sich die ausgedacht hat, Aber aus meiner
Sicht ist er da irgendeinem Spinner aufgesessen, der einem vom Pferd erzählt hat.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Man muss dazu sagen, der Artikel ist ja letztlich auch auf seinem Blog erschienen,
weil er nämlich keine Zeitung so übernehmen wollte.
Das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass das mit seinen Berichten passiert.
Und gut, das kann alle möglichen Gründe haben, aber das kann eben auch den Grund haben,
eben genau die journalistische Sorgfalt, die sich dann das veröffentlichende
Medium davon verspricht, nicht getroffen wird.
Auch wenn die Unterstellung natürlich ist, dass die Berichterstattung nicht
staatskonform genug ist. Das ist natürlich dann so der andere der dann gleich
noch hinterher geworfen wird.
Aus meiner Sicht ist die ganze Aktion mit den Pipelines so bekloppt.
Also egal, wie man sie jetzt zuschreiben möchte, sie macht einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn.
So richtig macht sie für keinen Sinn.
Aber man kann natürlich irgendwie einen Sinn konstruieren.
Aber so richtig ist es eigentlich eine komplett dämliche Aktion.
Also für die USA ist es eine dämliche Aktion,
weil wenn es rauskommt und früher oder später kommen solche Sachen fast immer raus,
dann wäre der Schaden so immens und der Nutzen zu dem Zeitpunkt war,
ich meine, es floss eh kein Gas mehr.
So klar kann man jetzt sagen, okay, wir wollten jetzt irgendwie auf Nummer sicher
gehen, dass da auch nicht wieder Gas fließt und dass die Europäer nicht erpressbar sind.
Aber umgekehrt bei Russland,
wenn ich frage, warum sollten die die eigene Pipeline sprengen,
Gut, aber bei Russland wundert man sich ständig über die Dinge,
die sie tun, die überhaupt gar keinen Sinn machen.
Insofern allein, weil es irgendwie keinen Sinn macht, könnte man schon fast
sagen, weiß das irgendwo auf die Russen hin.
Wobei es dann aus russischer Logik doch insofern Sinn machen könnte,
als dass man eben dann nicht schadenersatzpflichtig wird.
Wiederum dann auch Gerüchte jetzt da sind, dass die Russen wohl versuchen,
das Ding gerade zu reparieren oder versucht haben sollen jetzt schon das zu reparieren.
Wobei, wenn man jetzt sagt, die Russen, heißt das jetzt nicht,
dass irgendwie dort alle Bescheid wissen.
Das kann auch, sondern das kann was weiß ich gewesen.
Mit Sicherheit wissen da nicht alle Bescheid, wenn da alle Bescheid wissen,
dann wissen wir das auch.
Also, ja ja, also das ist, ich meine, wie auch immer das gemeint ist,
das könnte ja auch genauso einfach nur so als final, das ist ja so die andere These,
ja, jetzt ist die Pipeline jetzt so nichts mehr, gut, jetzt können wir sie auch
einfach sprengen, um dann einfach wieder 1000 Verschwörungstheorien in Gang
zu setzen mit, guck mal hier, die Welt ist gegen uns, sie zerstört unsere Pipelines.
Und was irgendwie aber auch überhaupt keinen Sinn macht, warum nur drei von
vier Leitungen zerstört worden sind.
So war das dann jetzt, weil das jetzt Absicht war,
irgendwie wer auch immer das getan hat, zu unfähig, um irgendwie auch die vierte
Röhre zu sprengen, ist da irgendwas schiefgegangen. so.
Also das Ganze ist und bleibt mysteriös, auch nach dem was Herr Starr geschrieben
hat. Das hat leider nicht wirklich Licht in die Sache gebracht, muss man sagen.
Gut, jetzt bleibt nur noch die Frage, haben wir wieder Licht in die Sache gebracht für euch?
Heute war das mal so ein bisschen nachdenklichere Sendung.
Wir wollten einfach mal so ein paar Themen durchrollen und uns nicht jetzt nur
so an den News festmachen.
Paar Sachen haben wir jetzt auch noch aufgeschoben, da kommen wir dann später
sicherlich auch noch dazu. Es gibt so viele Blickwinkel, mit denen man auf diesen
ganzen Konflikt blicken kann. So internationale Macht Balance und was da jetzt
irgendwie mit China noch läuft.
Es gibt natürlich jetzt auch kurzfristig noch die Fragen bezüglich des kommenden Kriegsverlaufs.
Wird Belarus dann noch in irgendeiner Form eine neue Front aufmachen etc.
Das werden wir dann vielleicht später nochmal aufgreifen. Dafür war jetzt heute
kein Raum. Ja, oder? Dann können wir doch jetzt erstmal den Deckel drauf machen auf dieser Sendung.
Ein Jahr Krieg ist vorbei. Wir wünschen uns alle sehr, dass es kein weiteres Jahr werden wird,
um diesen Krieg in irgendeiner Form zu beenden, aber sicher sagen kann es irgendwie
zu diesem Zeitpunkt keiner.
Also im Moment bereiten sich beide Seiten darauf vor, glaube ich,
dass das noch jahrelang weitergehen wird.
So zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Na gut, ich meine, die Ukraine muss sich darauf vorbereiten,
dass es so lange weitergehen kann.
Weil in gewisser Hinsicht dieser Konflikt mit Russland, selbst wenn der Krieg
abebt, so erstmal nicht vorbei sein wird.
Von daher sehe ich schon, dass dieses Land Planung macht, sowohl im Wochen-,
Monats-, Jahres- und auch Dekadenzeitraum.
Gar keine Frage. Die Frage ist ja, wie lange bleiben Truppen in der Ukraine?
Ja, aber auch im Westen hat man sich jetzt, ich sag mal,
zur Waffenlieferung beispielsweise kommittelt, die gar nicht dieses Jahr erfolgen werden,
sondern erst im nächsten Jahr und teilweise vielleicht sogar erst,
ja, also Deutschland hat Aufträge, glaube ich,
mit Panzer-Aubitze 2000,
die, weiß nicht, glaube ich 2026 oder 2027 die letzten dann erst ausgeliefert
werden und also insofern sieht es leider nach einem längeren Konflikt aus und
es ist auch nicht absehbar,
dass im Moment einer Seite komplett die Munition oder die Leute ausgehen werden,
um den Krieg weiterzuführen, sondern im Moment richten sich beide Seiten auf einen langen Krieg ein.
Das kann man glaube ich feststellen und das ist natürlich nicht schön.
Wir wollen ja auch mal über was anderes reden. Das machen wir vielleicht trotzdem
noch mal zwischendurch, aber jetzt gehen wir zumindest dem Konflikt noch nicht von der Seite.
Ja ich sage tschüss, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir hören uns dann bald.
Macht's gut. Ja, haltet die Uhr an steif.